we're basically not gamers
we
have a history of playing some games for
sure and have played this game and it's
been beautiful but to say we're a gamer
would be you know
would be ridiculous
music kind of
you know whether you like it or not it
triggers certain
feelings in you it triggers you know
certain uh and that's why it's so
powerful you know that's why it can be
so sneaky also like you know to
to make you feel stuff that you didn't
necessarily want to reveal you know and
the music can kind of go go um you know
the back the back door towards
manipulating your feelings and also
manipulating your like level of
excitement or you're like you know
your uh will to take action or move
faster or like you know turn to the
right or you know so so it's it's um
it's a bit of a
manipulative
medium
yeah and it's also i mean
within the game environment it's the
only thing that tells you the time's
about to wrap really so it's like
there's also these functional properties
where it's
you know
it's ultimately
yeah it's telling you to
to get a move on it's a really sort of
like um
in some ways it's just pure information
as well as being this emotional kind of
narrative journey so i don't know it
occupies a really interesting space i
think
some parts of the process were
incredibly heavy you know there was a
lot of sort of conceptual talk within
the within the sound design department
which
you know
uh is less standard maybe in in films
unless you're you know you're really
lucky and you have a really
coherent sort of
sound design team and musicians team
that want to really fuse together um
most of the time
they're fairly distinct and within the
games department it's all you're really
just the audio engine and so you're all
you you meet every week for 18 months as
the audio engine you know the team and
you discuss
you discuss the entire sort of
conceptual
uh
sound world that you're trying to build
um
so that's that's a really heavy
discussion but heavy also somehow has a
bit of a
negative tinge to it i thought it was
thrilling the whole way through so i
don't know about you like it's it's a
it's a deep discussion but if what
you're interested in is
a year and a half long discussion about
how to create a you know a sound world
for a place that doesn't exist then
you know if you want heavy um
i would say
yeah
yeah i guess you have to be in a bit
better conversation because
one um
when the audio i mean one not just the
audio when everything is interactive you
know it's not just like you know
elements standing on their own as they
are you know they have to be able to all
the elements have to be able to respond
to what the player is doing you know
obviously there has to be a bit more
uh interactivity also within the
different elements of the game you know
and therefore there has to be kind of
more um
uh everyone has to know what the next
person is doing a little bit more than
perhaps in films because you know you
can just in the final edit of the film
you can just decide like okay now now
this is like now the sound design is
louder now the music is not you know so
it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a different dialogue but
yeah yeah and the thing that you're
doing ostensibly doesn't exist up until
you know
up until
everyone has completed their work it's
sort of this strange exponential curve
of creation where you know everyone is
beginning to create but nothing exists
and then it all comes together in the
last weeks whereas in a film it's got a
more standard flow to it right so you're
you know most of the time unless you're
hilda and lucky enough to get to
start working on
music miles before the field's been shot
like most people just receive an edit
and some semi-complete and sound design
and they're just like okay i'm working
into these parameters but um
very much isn't the case with games um
so it's more
somehow more abstract in in
in the process you've got to do a lot of
imagining
yeah because then you also don't know
what the player is going to do right you
know you don't know how the player is
going to interact like you know there
was some
some
so so in some ways like the music
doesn't even exist until the player
plays that particular game because it's
gonna change anyway
every single time it's played so so it's
it's uh um
you know there's there's things that you
also have to consider like you know that
certain types of sounds are going to
make the player interact and you know
turn around or you know there's like
those kind of elements that
yeah we had a really i think it's it's
kind of fun to talk about because we're
basically not gamers you know like we uh
we
we have a history of playing some games
for sure and have played this game and
it's been beautiful but to say we're a
gamer would be you know
would be ridiculous it's like it's not
it's not necessarily our
area of expertise so we we come at this
with sort of wide-eyed enthusiasm but
not necessarily um
like
there was a lot of things to learn
through the process and i think when
we're creating sound worlds that are
where the line between sound design and
music is
deliberately so um
so close you know you're not really sure
what is
the the world you know a sort of foley
sound of the world and what is the music
beginning to sort of creep to life
you encounter problems
occasionally where
a musical element that we're like oh but
it's so cool because it fits into the
world so well
the player goes okay so why am i hearing
the sound in my left ear
like what is that is that someone doing
something to my left i should i should
check over here
and the music influences the play in a
way that's not desirable it's not never
a problem you encounter in film
because you know the screen doesn't move
um
so
there was lots of
yeah lots of that process of sort of
teasing and testing and a couple of
sounds that we we literally had we
literally had to make less literal we uh
we had to sort of
bring back from the
the sort of
slightly bring more into a more musical
context than perhaps the original idea
was
just because the player was interacting
with
the sound as though it was sounding
effects rather than the music itself so
that was pretty fun
there are definitely more direct routes
to getting a score and the way that we
went about it i think we just we were
really
and and the team that dice also really
encouraged that they were just like we
we
you know in their words they sort of
hired us to
to do
so that they wouldn't get a traditional
game score you know and there was
there's some vulnerability in that like
because obviously
you know if you if you slap like
big kicks and a chugging orchestra on
top of something it's kind of
you know it's going to do the thing it's
going to do the thing but they were like
they didn't want to play it safe
and
so
we went a really indirect way of of of
coming round to what ultimately ended up
in the game
and
uh
yeah
which was very much kind of fueled with
with uh exploration
rather than
like you know
knowing necessarily you know so
real curiosity yeah exactly which is
because i and i i think that's kind of
and that's what they were interested in
like you know because our our
you know lack of experience met that we
were seeing everything was so fresh eyes
you know and and therefore like you know
we'd
we would go
probably into in different directions
than someone who who is like knows
exactly how the ropes were you know
for us the thing that was exciting about
the project was actually the worlds
themselves so it's kind of the
we knew the people going to be running
around shooting each other and that that
has action in it there's action and
excitement and there's all this going on
but it wasn't that that necessarily
attracted us to the project itself it
was these like colossal worlds in this
post sort of like
you know mid climate collapse kind of
near future
that
and so there's a sort of tension
between the fact that for us that we
were really trying to do world building
we're like trying to make the music a
part of the world themselves like really
use the materials from each of the
levels and really bring the whole world
to life so that as a player you're kind
of engulfed in the the real kind of
physicality of the world you've got the
visual elements the sound design the
music and it's all pulling over you in
this kind of chaotic and intense kind of
way
and you've got that tension because you
need to drive the player forward you
know you're not you can't abandon the
player musically and just be dealing
with the world itself
but at the same time
you're not just we're not just focusing
on the player like we're focusing
we're really wanting to look at the
world and dwarf the player so it's you
know what i mean there's a kind of
tension between these two things
and
i remember like halfway through the
process
we
we delivered some you know for the end
of the end of a level uh
we delivered some music that was perhaps
a touch more melancholic than and that's
by our standards i think it's pretty
melancholic what's in there anyway but
um but you know this
this pretty sad piece of music for the
end of a round and the audio team came
back and they're like well in this case
you've kind of abandoned the player
because you play the player needs to
feel pumped win or lose they need to
feel pumped at the end of a round and we
were like but it they've just died in a
climate like you know it's it's this
awful world and they've just
they've just died and
and you know andreas the head of the
sound team came back and he's like you
got to remember that
in the game itself
dying is of relatively little
consequence it's not like a film where
if the main character dies in a film you
know
you're in you know you it's a moment in
a game it doesn't really have much
weight in five seconds you just
you know you're back again or if you're
us you know we die all the time playing
this game it's worth saying like reduce
like
but it's over very little consequence so
you get this kind of interesting tension
between
wanting to build the world without
abandoning the player
and also
avoiding focusing too much on the player
and
abandoning the world itself you know
it's there's a real balance there it's
quite interesting
[Music]